23 November die o'onnel Street im
Zentrum Dublins ein Mob aus
rechtsextremen und Jugendlichen zündet
Busse und Polizeiautos an Auslöser die
Tat eines geistig verwirrten
algerischstämmigen Iren der mehrere
Kinder und eine Lehrerin mit dem Messer
verletzt sofort verbreiten rechtsextreme
Falschinformationen gegen die
Einwanderungspolitik der irischen
Regierung ein beispielloser Vorfall im
bisher so toleranten
Irland die
Bilder legten sich wie eine Art
Blaupause auf den neuen Roman des
irischen Schriftstellers paul linch
propong ist eine Dystopie über ein
faschistisches Irland der plötzliche
Gewaltausbruch kam für linch nicht
überraschend die Wahrheit ist die dass
in den Staaten der westlichen Welt die
Zivilisation das Ideal ist das
Stammesdenken aber gleichzeitig als
Instinkt fortlebt das Ideal der
Zivilisation zerstören ziemlich einfach
man muss den Leuten nur die Dinge die
das Leben angenehm machen wegnehmen
erschwert man ihnen das Leben kommt das
Stammesdenken zum Vorschein und das
können wir gerade überall beobachten
eine Politik die das nationalistische
des Stammesdenken adressiert sobald die
Politik aber diesen Weg einschlägt muss
man nur noch die entsprechenden Knöpfe
drücken bis wir dort ankommen wo niemand
von uns sein
will auch in Irland profitieren bei
weitem nicht alle vom Wirtschaftsboom
der seit den 90er Jahren andauert und
Irland vom armen Haus zu einem der
reichsten Länder gemacht hat spätestens
seit der Pandemie treten die Probleme
immer deutlicher hervor drogenschwämme
Bildungsmisere und vor allem die
grassierende Wohnungsnot viele ihren
werfen der Politik in Zeiten steigender
Einwanderer Zahlen Konzeptlosigkeit vor
und auch die Ressentiments sind
unüberhörbar die Regierung muss etwas
gegen die Wohnungsnot tun und gegen die
Bildungsmisere die vielen Obdachlosen
das ist das was die Leute
die regier n noch mehr Leute
unterzuingen
versucht die und die Iren haben diese
ganzen Leute satt die ins Land kommen
ohne überprüft zu werden und diese armen
Jugendlichen müssen nun den Preis dafür
zahlen ein Teil der irischen Bevölkerung
ist die unkontrollierte Einwanderung
leid wenn manele
Einwand wissen wie man sie integriert
bedeutet das dass es vielleicht nicht
genug Transportmittel Bildungs und
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten
gibt dabei gilt Irland als einer der
gastfreundlichsten Staaten Europas seit
der großen Hungersnot Mitte des 19
Jahrhunderts notgedrungen
Auswanderungsland zieht es seit den 90er
Jahren immer mehr Menschen an doch über
die Aufnahme der wachsenden
Flüchtlingsströme wirkt das Land
zusehens gespalten
wir hatten hier einen
einwanderungsstau während der Pandemie
wurden viele Asylanträge blockiert und
verschoben dazu kamen die vielen Krisen
in der Welt und um Europa herum plus der
brexit und die Krise in Großbritannien
das verändert gerade alles und wir
befinden uns in einer schwierigen
Situation aber wir sind zuversichtlich
dass die Iren diese Aufgabe gut
bewältigen
werden
Irlands größte und hausgemachte
Herausforderung ist die
Wohnungskrise seit dem Zuzug der
Hightech Giganten aus den USA die in
Irland kaum Steuern zahlen sind zwar die
Löhne aber auch mieten und Häuserpreise
exorbitant gestiegen der freie Markt
zielt fast nur auf die Wohlhabenden
während der soziale Wohnungsbau über
Jahrzehnte sträflich vernachlässigt
wurde beklagt der Lehrer und
mietrechtler
auch dieses improvisierte Kulturzentrum
im Stadtteil fipsb wird demnächst für
teure Eigentumswohnungen
geräumt die Unterschicht hier muss seit
vielen Jahren ein hartes Leben aushalten
nicht nur die die obdachlos geworden
sind sondern auch die Mieter wer bis zu
70% seines Gehalts für die Mieter
aufbringen muss für den ist es schwer
sich aus dieser Misere zu befreien
manche fallen nun auf die extreme Rechte
herein die ihnen vorgaugelt dass die
Einwanderer daran schld sein weil sie
ihnen alles
wegnehmen das ist natürlich Unsinn und
zugleich eine gefährliche Lüge denn
jeder schiebt gerne etwas auf einen
Bösewicht doch so leicht das ist es
schafft nur Zwietracht und
Hass auch wenn die Krawallmacher vor
allem desorientierte Jugendliche waren
für die Einwohner von Dublin war der
Gewaltausbruch auf der Cony Street ein
Schock wie empfänglich die ihren
zukünftig für die Einflussnahme von V
recht sind dafür ist auch die sozial und
Wohnungspolitik der Regierung
entscheidend in den prophetischen Zeilen
von Paul linch ist nicht nur die Zukunft
Irlands sondern aller westlichen Staaten
umschrieben wenn du sagst eine Sache ist
eine andere und du sagst es oft genug
dann ist es auch so und wenn du es immer
und immer wieder sagst dann nehmen die
Leute es als wahr ein alter Gedanke
natürlich wirklich neu ist das nicht
aber du siehst zu passiert und nicht in
einem Buch früher oder später offenbart
sich die Wirklichkeit natürlich eine
Zeit lang kann man die Wirklichkeit
beleihen doch die Wirklichkeit wartet
immer geduldig stumm dann fordert sie
einen Preis und bringt die Waage wieder
ins
Lot noch gilt Irland als Musterbeispiel
für Demokratie und Toleranz die
Europawahlen Anfang Juni werden zeigen
ob auch hier die bislang noch
unbedeutenden rechtsextremen Partei an
Einfluss gewinnen
können